[Music]
the view uh defect you're overconfident
kind of this great voicing your
confidence brother in the week just felt
like you know had a lot of confidence in
this football team not have gotta trust
a lot of faith and the guys and is this
the worst loss since you've been here
it's either one or two yes well I'm sure
dinner all right
[Music]
that's a little demarcus Lawrence
talking about Doug Peterson before that
a little Doug Peterson talking about
Doug Peterson his non guarantee
guarantee from last week the moment that
he didn't double down Chris last week
because remember just to set the scene
here she was on WIP radio in Philly last
Monday and just very nonchalantly we're
gonna go down and they were gonna win
but and up reporters asked him later
today hey talk about your guarantee what
guarantee I didn't guarantee anything
well you did and I think the fact that
he wobbled on a little bit took
something away from it didn't take
anything away from it for the cow blow
not that got them focused that got them
motivated contributed at that sense that
the team is under siege the Jason
Garrett's on the hot scene I think they
live for those moments where it feels
like the walls are closing in they find
a better level of performance and we saw
it last night with a 37 to 10 win yeah
they are a team that does seem to thrive
on you know external motivation when
somebody else says something or you guys
aren't good anymore you know we saw it
last year they were three and five they
go seven seven and one down the stretch
but you know in my experience with those
guys look Rod Marinelli especially on
the defensive side of the ball I know he
is the type of guy that could use it as
something to fire his defense up
definitely and especially a guy like
DeMarcus Lawrence who hasn't played up
to his contract to this point yet and
you know what yesterday he pops a few
times in the game and it was maybe just
enough to kind of get them over the edge
to focus in on some of the details and
things they had been messing up on their
three-game losing streak another guy who
popped last night after getting the big
contract following the holdout Ezekiel
Elliott 22 carries 111 yards and a
touchdown he had six yazi 36 yards and
it seemed like he had that little that
will pop back right right and you you
were careful to point out you're not
saying he'd lost his step but there were
moments where it looked like the syke
voled would have gotten more yardage out
of the play yes and he had a little more
that zip in his step last night than
what we'd seen I think so I mean I
thought it from the the first carry of
the night just running up the middle you
saw you know explosion a little bit more
of a running style instead of maybe oh
let me see if I find the right hole here
and try to find it that way I felt like
last night he just said you know I'm
gonna get the ball I'm going down
he'll if I missed the whole so what but
I'm gonna do it aggressively and make
people pay for getting in the way and
yeah he got some tougher and yards there
and I thought it was the best he has
looked really in the last two years I
would say and I think the simple
explanation is that the Cowboys won
those first three games of the season so
easily they allowed themselves to think
it was just gonna continue to be easier
and once they went to New Orleans and
got a little cold water in the face and
then they come home and the Packers come
down and take it it's you know you got
it you got a fight to get yourself back
to and yeah they were wobbling a little
and-and-and and I think what happened in
the aftermath of last week's loss really
did kind of propel them forward but you
know what they've done one pass through
the division and they've dominated
everyone in the division yes they have
so I what do you think like do you think
the cab like I still think the Cowboys
are for real like I do I know I might be
in the minority I know that's only four
and three but I look at that team and go
I think they can make a run and still be
a really big-time player in the NFC do
you feel the same way well think back to
last year yeah they were three and five
and they were limping into Philadelphia
on a Sunday night they've played the
Eagles on Sunday night football since
NBC's had the package 12 out of 13 years
so for the the 2018 annual Cowboys
Eagles Sunday night game yeah everyone
was saying the same things that we were
saying maybe even worse right if they
get blown out if it's ugly Jason Garrett
may get fired and they found a way to
win that game it was 27 to 20 not the
same quality of ball but was on the road
yeah
and they went seven and won the second
half of the season so sometimes that
that that kick that punched that thing
that wakes you up continues and I think
that now we'll see if they can do this
year what they did last year which is
use that win over Philadelphia is the
momentum to really kind of take off the
rest of the way so I think they can you
do I think I can't I was waiting for you
to get to the final statement to say
yeah I think so you try to support I
know that's why that's why I support it
because last year they did it yeah sure
all right well yeah the other thing too
we talked a lot about last week like
follow the money right and then they
have guys that are not performing up to
their contracts Zeke better
DeMarcus Lawrence gets the strip Zach
fumble on the second drive how about
Jaylon Smith the guy they signed them to
a big contract before the season started
he gets the fumble on the first drive by
not
Dallas got hurt you know hitting him
hard knocking the ball loose so those
are all positive signs for the Dallas
Cowboys and that's what they do need you
know they need dominant they're a star
driven team and they pay their stars and
they expect their stars to carry the
squad through tough times and last night
was one of those tough times and they
win the football game by week in week
eight and you hate to take a week yeah
for having a game like that at the
Giants on a Monday night coming up week
nine so they actually have an extra day
on top of their bye week then it's like
a thing this year I feel like there's
been a few teams that have had that for
the 49ers did that 15 day break then
it's a short week and a visit from the
Vikings on Sunday Night Football at the
Lions after that at the Patriots on
November 24 income the bills for
Thanksgiving at the Bears the Rams at
the Eagles and Washington end the season
really after coming off thereby we got
the Giants they should win that one
easily yes and Washington at the end of
the season everything in between is off
game yes it is they they're they're
gonna have to play quality football on
both sides of the ball to beat a lot of
those teams certainly and and and we
know they're they're extremely talented
Dallas there's not going to be a team
really they walk on the field with where
you're gonna go oh they're really
outmatched there there's not one area
the team you can look at the Cowboys and
go oh yeah they're physically
underwhelming here or they don't match
up with this team blah blah blah you
know I think they are one of the more
talented teams in football when they
take care of the ball and maximize
what's there to be had they're pretty
tough too
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports